you mentioned that the right hemisphere
is
involved in understanding
and understanding your meaning okay
what does meaning mean
well yes a very good question
do
any word you like the left hemisphere
has one idea of it on the right hand is
for a different one
so
to the left hemisphere meaning is
something that is as you might expect
put together from bits
and it could be something we create by
you know words are tokens they're put
together by
systematic
syntax and they turn into a meaning the
computer might be able to find out of
the combination of a dictionary and a
book of grammar rules
but meaning is not that when i say
uh that
there is meaning in certain experiences
like the you know my my wife means
everything to me
or this piece of music means so much
or you know just being able to walk in
wilderness is so important and
it brings meaning to things now
what i want to stress is that nowadays
when people
um
allow that there could be meaning coming
from certain experiences they see that
as
an invention of ours so we do this and
we think okay now we've added some
meaning but that's not the image that's
the left hemisphere image of something
that is added to something else
mechanically what i'm saying is we are
in certain experiences made to be more
receptive
more aware
of something that is there to be brought
into being through the commerce between
ourselves our own consciousness and
whatever it is that
we're conscious of
so it's a relational thing absolutely at
its core is relation and at its core
it's consciousness
so in this way i found that
you're a physicist that
surprisingly a lot of physicists have
written to me since the master in his
emissary was published saying this is
very important and interesting from our
point of view
and in the book that i've just finished
and want to publish in the next few
months called the matter with things
i take three ways of looking at the
world one is
neuroscience
one is
philosophy and the third is physics and
i show that quite coherently by pursuing
each of these powers we can come to a
vision of
a picture of the world which is
very very different from the one that
we're taught
and that which the popular media and the
the vox pop of sort of scientists who do
too much talking and not enough thinking
i would suggest